Film Courage: So many independent filmmakers only get
a chance to make one feature film which
is so true usually they're tapped out
financially usually.  You've been
fortunate to do so many. What do you
attribute that to?
Filmmaker Richard Linklater: I don't know. Low budgets compel. I don't
know. I think it now's a good time to be
a filmmaker you know technology's
helping you can keep the budgets low and
get your films made you know that's good
but I think what's good about the
current media environment you really can
make a film and see if it's what you're
meant to be doing you know I always felt
really comfortable making films that's
how I think that's what I think about
that's who I am you know but writing a
novel would be tougher for me it's not
my mentality you know so some people I
think they want to make films they make
one you realize um you know maybe that's
not my medium so it's just finding your
right medium I was lucky to fairly early
on hit on it that's just the terms I
think in but you know the industry
changes a lot but the the core mission
of most filmmakers who just tell stories
that are meaningful to them that that
never changes